[Musique]
jean-philippe ni l'or bonjour bonjour
vous êtes le député sortant de la 4e
circonscription celle du sud c'est votre
troisième candidature qu'est ce qui vous
motive encore ce qui me motive ce sont
tous les challenges que la martinique
doit relever aujourd'hui
c'est aussi le fait que après l'élection
présidentielle on sait que les années à
venir seront difficiles d'ailleurs le
président de la république lui-même a
annoncé qui va durcir les choses
notamment l'accession des outre-mer donc
nous avons d'autant plus besoin de
parlementaires qui soit à la fois
expérimenté qui maîtrise les dossiers et
je crois l'avoir démontré tout au long
de ces deux mandatures mais surtout des
parlementaires que le courage de prendre
des positions d'être véritablement des
fidèles porte parole d'un peuple et de
ses aspirations par des parlementaires
qui soit quelque part des agents de
communication du gouvernement
la question que l'on doit vous bouzy à
chaque fois dans quel état d'esprit
êtes-vous face à alfred marie jeanne
vous avez été la première fois soutenu
par alfred marie-jeanne le mime la
seconde mandature vous êtes richie
quasiment seul et tu la mettais sur
présente contre vous c'est son doigt et
là le doigt de se présenter contre moi
je dois simplement dire qu'il n'ya pas
que monsieur marie-jeanne face à moi
mais ce n'est pas l'eau des
concurrents je dois manifester et
exprimer le même respect et pour tous
les candidats mais certes est clair que
une charge symbolique qui est
particulière dans cette élection du sud
entre celui qui a contribué à mon
éclosion politique et et moi même je
crois que la question qui se pose tout
simplement delà de tout l'aspect
émotionnel c'est de savoir qui
aujourd'hui est le meilleur porte parole
du peuple martiniquais qui aujourd'hui
la capacité à vous représenter le peuple
martiniquais noten singulièrement le
peuple du sud à l'assemblée nationale
pour défendre son peuple à travers des
propositions de lois travers des
amendements à travers des interventions
questions écrites questions orales et
cetera c'est tout le travail de
parlementaire qu'on doit questionner
aujourd'hui pour savoir lequel de nous
deux ou lequel de nos 15 puisque je
crois qu'il ya quinze candidats dans le
sud est le mieux placé pour siéger et
représenter la martinique en tant que
député je dois dire que je suis sur
l'échelle de la martinique le seul
député qui se représente ça veut dire
que de toutes façons d'être tous les cas
de figure si je suis réélu je suis je
serai le député le plus expérimenté
celui qui connaît le mieux le
fonctionnement les arcanes de
l'assemblée nationale et je me devrai
forcément d'accompagner mes collègues
députés martiniquais de quelque bord
qu'ils soient pour faciliter leur
intégration et c'est dans cet état
d'esprit que je m'inscris quels sont les
deux trois projets prioritaires pour
vous mettre la question prioritaire pour
moi c'est la question sanitaire et je
les ai toujours dit la question les
questions relatives à la santé publique
sont des questions qui sont essentiels
j'ai porté au cours de la dernière
législature un certain nombre de
dossiers notamment inquiet qui a permis
la décision de reconstruction et de
financement de la reconstruction de
l'hôpital de trinité et dans le cadre du
ségur de la santé de financement pour
l'hôpital du saint-esprit du foie soit
des trois ilets et c'est donc malgré
l'hostilité de la république à metz nous
avons pu obtenir ça et je crois avoir
été une cheville ouvrière
importante dans l'obtention de ces
résultats mais il faut aller beaucoup
plus loin aujourd'hui le combat pour la
santé c'est un combat pour la
réintégration des soignants qui ont été
injustement
sanctionné par le gouvernement
aujourd'hui la la réalité scientifique
heureusement a pris le dessus on sait
bien que vacciner ou pas on peut
transmettre la maladie à partir du
moment où tout le monde est d'accord sur
ce constat on doit être d'accord aussi
sur le fait qu'il était juste de
sanctionner des personnels soignants qui
ne sont pas vaccinés ça sans combat à
porter l'autre combat essentiel c'est le
combat en faveur
de la production martiniquaise un pays
comme la martinique ne peut pas se
développer si apam production
martiniquaise et la production
martiniquaise doit être encadré d'être
protégé quelque part par un certain
nombre de textes de loi donc nous allons
développer sa bière il n'y a pas
d'emploi sans production et la priorité
martiniquaise à l'emploi doit être
une constante de notre action politique
à tous et aussi la priorité
martiniquaise à l'accès au foncier parce
qu'aujourd'hui la martinique se vend par
internet à des gens qui n'ont jamais mis
les pieds en matinée dernière question
vraiment trop maximum 30 secondes
qu'avez vous à dire aux électeurs
martiniquais
j'ai dit aux électeurs martiniquais mais
non merci parce que c'est grâce à votre
ton confiance c'est grâce à votre
soutien que j'ai la force d'aller porter
un certain nombre de combats et pour moi
c'est un honneur de parler en votre nom
de défendre mon peuple de défendre
au-delà de la martinique même ceux qu'on
appelle les peuples d'outre-mer
de défendre ces populations là c'est un
honneur pour moi et c'est une motivation
et c'est pourquoi
sachant les difficultés à venir sachant
les périodes difficiles qui s'ouvre
devant nous que je me présente à cette
élection et que je sollicite de nouveau
votre confiance je crois que vous avez
vu que je pouvais être digne de
confiance et que je ne doute n'oubliez
pas que je devais tout au peuple
martiniquais jean philippe miller je
vous remercie merci
[Musique]